one of the most invaluable principles
anyone can follow
is to draw lessons from the mistakes and
experiences of others particularly those
who have navigated the world's
imperfections and still found joy within
its confines
such profound insights are what one can
glean from the life and works of Charles
Bukowski
the problem with the world is that the
intelligent people are full of doubts
while the stupid ones are full of
confidence
we don't even ask for happiness just a
little less pain
beware of those who seek constant crowds
they are nothing alone
if you have the ability to love
yourself first
wherever the Crowd Goes run in the other
direction
they're always wrong
some people like what you do some people
hate what you do
but most people simply don't give a damn
too often the people complain that they
have done nothing with their lives and
then wait for somebody to tell them that
this isn't so
the crowd is the Gathering Place of the
weakest
true creation is a solitary Act
success is always dangerous
it can make an out of anybody
if you're going to try go all the way
otherwise don't even start
what matters most is how well you walk
through the fire
I don't hate people I just feel better
when they're not around
sometimes you climb out of bed in the
morning
and you think
I'm not going to make it but you laugh
inside
remembering all the times you felt that
way
we are here to laugh at the odds and
live our lives so well
that death will tremble to take us
beauty is nothing
Beauty won't stay
you don't know how lucky you are to be
ugly because of people like you you know
it's for something else
people are strange
they are constantly angered by trivial
things
but on a major matter like totally
wasting their lives
they hardly seem to notice
nobody can save you but yourself
and you're worth saving
it's a war not easily won
but if anything is worth winning
then this is it
of course it's possible to love a human
being
if you don't know them too well
bad taste creates many more millionaires
than good taste
your ambition is handicapped by laziness
there is nothing that teaches you more
than regrouping after failure and moving
on
the less you need the better you feel
we're all going to die
all of us
what a circus
that alone should make us love each
other
but it doesn't
find what you love and let it kill you
things get bad for all of us almost
continually
and what we do under constant stress
reveals who or what we are
you have to die a few times before you
can really live
real loneliness is not necessarily
limited to when you are alone
sleeping in the Lion's Den doesn't make
you a lion
there is always one woman to save you
from another
and as that woman saves you
she makes ready to destroy
there are only two things wrong with
money
too much or too little
Simplicity is always the secret
to a profound truth
to doing things to writing to painting
life is profound in its simplicity
can you remember who you were before the
world told you who you should be
if something burns your soul with
purpose and desire
it's your duty to be reduced to ashes by
it
any other form of existence will be yet
another dull book in the library of life
nothing is worse than to finish a good
then reach over and find the toilet
paper container empty
even the most horrible human being on
Earth deserves to wipe his ass
the only time most people think about
Injustice is when it happens to them
there are worse things than being alone
but it often takes decades to realize
this and most often when you do it's too
late
and there's nothing worse than too late
if you're losing your soul and you know
it
then you've still got a soul Left to
Lose
and why do women always need the
husbands of other women
and why do horse thieves always prefer a
tamed horse to a wild one
if a woman lacks sex for a long time
soon she will begin to understand that
she wants more than just physical
contact
Geelong for an emotional bond that
vibrates in harmony with her heart beats
to truly make a difference in the world
start by helping one person at a time
anything more grandiose than this
is either overly idealistic or
politically motivated
love is a form of prejudice
you love what you need you love what
makes you feel good you love what is
convenient
genius might be the ability to say a
profound thing in a simple way
a love is like a serious illness
an illness from which you never entirely
recover
we are like flowers that never took the
chance to bloom when we should have
and it's as if life has grown tired of
waiting for us